Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Manchester United hat kein Trainer Mourinho mehr. Es gibt jetzt einen Nachfolger und auch sonst ist so einiges passiert in der Premier League, Höchste Zeit für uns mal wieder rüber zu gucken mit Dasein-Kommentator Uli Hebel. Uli, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt. Hi.
Grüß dich, ich freu mich auch.
Ach, sehr schön. So ein herzliches, fröhliches Grüß Gott. Das hört man sicherlich auch gerne in der Podcast-Landschaft. Und wir haben den perfekten Zeitpunkt gefunden, um mal wieder über die Premier League zu sprechen. Die Entlassung von José Mourinho war da der Aufhänger. Und du hast mir gerade im Vorgespräch verraten, du hättest mir schon gestern sagen können, dass Solskjaer Nachfolger wird.
Ja, ich hab's tatsächlich schon gestern so am frühen bis späten Nachmittag gewusst, dass das wohl so sein wird, wenn sich da nicht wirklich jetzt noch eine Lösung auftut, die dann schon brauchbar wäre für die mittelfristige bis langfristige Zukunft. Dann würde man mit Solskjaer gehen, der eine Klausel im Vertrag bei Molde hatte, dass er jederzeit zugunsten den Uniteds verlassen könnte. Und Karik sowie auch McKenna, die beiden Co-Trainer, Mourinhos bis dato, denen hat man das nicht zugetraut. Ist glaube ich auch ganz sinnvoll. Und daher hat man sich dann für Solskjaer entschieden, der das jetzt erst einmal bis zum Sommer macht. Und dann muss man sowieso mal schauen. Ich kann mir aber ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen, egal wie erfolgreich oder unerfolgreich er ist, dass er das dann darüber hinaus machen kann. Das ist wiederum auch nicht vorstellbar. Nee, glaube ich nicht. Also, sind wir mal ehrlich, bei allem Respekt für Uli Gunnar Solskjaer, der –ich zeige jetzt mal –Name ist nicht groß genug. Und das ist leider aus der Sicht Manchester United im Moment wichtiger als der sportliche Erfolg, dass die Namen passen, dass die Marke weiter fortgeführt wird. Und insofern, er könnte jetzt jedes einzelne Spiel gewinnen. Ich kann mir beim Besten nicht vorstellen, dass der dann den Zuschlag bekommt, glaube ich nicht.
Faszinierend. Und das, obwohl man ja glauben könnte, vielleicht hätte man da aus der Historie so ein bisschen gelernt, denn die großen Namen waren es ja seit Alex Ferguson auch nicht. Womit ich ganz gerne mit dir nochmal jetzt über die Zeit von Mourinho bei United sprechen würde. Gefühlt war er die ganze Zeit schon umstritten. Wie würdest du denn jetzt seine Zeit bei United zusammenfassen?
Ach, das ist ganz schwierig, weil es tatsächlich ganz viele kleinere Mosaiki gibt, die das verändern. Also ich würde mal folgendes sagen, und damit möchte ich ihn gar nicht verteidigen. Ich bin nicht sein Anwalt und ich hielt die Verpflichtung Mourinhos von vornherein für grundfalsch. Und ich bin prinzipiell darin bestätigt. Aber –und das habe ich auch immer wieder gesagt –letzte Saison hat er wirklich United gut entwickelt. Die waren auf einem Stand, wo wir alle dachten, der nächste Schritt ist getan, und sie sind in der Rangliste der Verfolger Manchester Citys auf zwei bis drei. Liverpool hat sie jetzt inzwischen überholt, da gibt es auch Gründe für. Die haben einfach einen allumfassenden Plan, genauso wie Manchester City auch. Den hatte Manchester United nicht. Aber Jürgen Klopp hat in seiner Zeit bei Liverpool genau Nulltrophäen geholt. Mauricio Pochettino, den viele ganz gerne als seinen Nachfolger hätten, also als Mourinhos Nachfolger bei Manchester United, hat in seiner Zeit bei Tottenham Nulltrophäen geholt. Chelsea Mourinho hat in seiner Zeit bei Manchester United Zwei Trophäen geholt und hat höhere Gewinnraten als die beiden genannten Manager. Das möchte ich nur noch mal sagen. Ich glaube, Mourinho alleine ist nicht schuld an dem, was da bei United läuft oder nicht läuft. Er hat sie in der ersten Saison auf Kurs gebracht, stabilisiert. Er hat sie in der zweiten Saison bei weitem stabilisiert. Dass er nie als Unterhalter dienen würde, war uns allen hoffentlich klar. Denn das ist einfach nicht seine Systematik. Aber Saison Nummer zwei würde ich ihm ausschließlich Positives attestieren. Mit der Ausnahme, ja, das muss man sagen, das ist auch das, was ich ihm immer wieder vorgeworfen habe, die jungen Spieler, die da sind und die, glaube ich, durchaus das Fundament bilden könnten einer zukünftig projiziert erfolgreichen United-Mannschaft, die sind teilweise hinten runtergefallen. Rashford ist da natürlich gemeint, Marcial ist da natürlich gemeint, sicherlich in Teilen auch Jesse Lingard, auch wenn der jetzt nicht zur durifizierten Zukunft gehören sollte. Aber da sind einfach links und rechts die Spieler hinten runtergefallen zu Ungunsten der erfahrenen Spieler. Aber auch das wusste man, wenn man Mourinho holt, dass er eher mit denen geht. Nur Saison Nummer zwei, komplett positiv. Und dann ging es ja ab Sommer los. Und ich glaube, da haben wir auch schon mal in unserem ersten Treffen in dieser Spielzeit darüber gesprochen, da ging es schon los, dass er sich auch öffentlich beschwert hatte, dass er die Spieler nicht bekam. Und in dem Moment, wo du öffentlich als Trainer Mourinho sagst, ich habe eine Liste abgegeben mit fünf Spielern, ich habe keinen davon bekommen, war uns allen klar, Hadeson. Und genauso ist es jetzt passiert. Jetzt hat er halt diesen in Anführungszeichen Machtkampf verloren. Aber mir ist ganz wichtig, immer wieder rauszustellen, schlussendlich ist Mourinho schuldig, weil du als Cheftrainer noch dazu einer, der über solche Macht verfügen möchte, immer einen Teil schuld hast, aber nicht im Ansatz ausschließlich, da sind ganz andere beteiligt.
Ja, das finde ich jetzt durchaus mal erfrischend, denn die gängige Meinung ist, glaube ich, Mourinho gegenüber sehr viel kritischer. Interessanterweise stützen dich ja auch so ein bisschen die Zahlen, wenn man sich mal anguckt, der Schnitt der Punkte pro Spiel, da gab es Sir Alex Ferguson, der unglaubliche 9.700 Tage im Amt war, der hatte einen 2,07er Schnitt und dann kommt aber schon von allen anderen United-Trainer, kommt schon José Mourinho und ja auch die Zweitplatzierung im letzten Jahr. Hast du ja schon angesprochen, das vergisst man immer so ein bisschen. Ich hatte aber den Eindruck, Uli, dass auch damals, also auch schon im letzten Jahr, weil es war ja auch ein sehr deutlicher zweiter Platz hinter einem überragenden Manchester City, dass da auch schon viel Kritik laut wurde. Also unter anderem nach dem Achtelfinal aus in der Champions League gegen Sevilla und auch ein bisschen befeuert durch seine Außendarstellung. Du hast jetzt gesagt, Mourinho ist nicht alleine schuld. Lass mal so ein bisschen einkreisen. Was sind die Probleme bei United und woher kommen sie eigentlich?
Also ich möchte, lass mich kurz einen Satz noch dazu sagen, weil du natürlich vollkommen recht hast, Champions League-Achtelfinale war vercoacht, schlicht und ergreifend, wissen auch alle, das war nicht gut und das weiß auch Mourinho. Aber das passiert halt mal in zwei Spielen europäischer Spitzenfußball, auch gegen Sevilla, das kann dir halt mal passieren. Und ich möchte ihn bei weitem nicht verteidigen, da war einiges schwach. Aber jetzt auf die andere Frage, weil die ist auch sehr wichtig. Seit Sir Alex Ferguson weggegangen ist, und das ist nicht nur Sir Alex Ferguson gewesen, das war auch David Gill, der seinerzeit CEO war, also im Grunde genommen so was wie der Geschäftsführer und starke Mann hinter Sir Alex. Es gab im sportlichen Bereich nur diesen einen starken Mann, aber im finanziellen Bereich war es David Gill und der hat ausschließlich gemacht, was Sir Alex Ferguson für sinnvoll hielt. Die beiden gingen Hand in Hand. Der ist mit ihm gegangen, mit Sir Alex Ferguson gegangen und seither, und das ist tatsächlich genau so belegbar, seither gingen die schlechten Entscheidungen los. Sechs Jahre voller Katastrophe. Es kam Ed Woodward als Chief Executive, zwischen Vice-Chairman auch. Das ist ein, einer mit Bankerhintergrund und man muss ihm lassen, die finanzielle wirtschaftliche Seite überragend. Da hat Manchester United noch mehr…
Jetzt wird wieder bei dir gebot, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es bröckelt in der Wohnung von Uli, zumindest wenn sein Nachbar so weiterbohrt, wie er es schon im Vorgespräch getan hat. Wir lassen das als Metapher einfach so im Hintergrund stehen.
Ich wollte nur den Rahmen schaffen, damit sich jeder genau hineinversetzen kann. Also, Ed Woodward ist als Mann mit Bankerhintergrund, hat Manchester United noch mehr als Weltmarke etabliert, als das sein Vorgänger David Gill schon machen konnte. Die Zahlen sind überragend und da kann ich ihm auch gar nicht, da fehlt mir komplett die Expertise dazu, dass ich ihm da in irgendeiner Weise irgendetwas abschreiben könnte. Aber sportlich ist der Mensch nicht in der Lage, sich mit Jose Mourinho auch nur im Ansatz auf Augenhöhe zu unterhalten. Er ist aber manches alternativ derjenige, der Mourinios Spielervorschläge, beispielsweise –ich gehe jetzt einfach mal auf das Plakativste ein –wenn Mourinho sagt, ich möchte diesen und diesen Spieler, dann ist Ed Woodward derjenige, der den Haken dahinter setzen muss oder aber ein Kreuz. Aber er hat einfach keinerlei Befähigungen, das tun zu dürfen. Es gibt die Überlegung seit zwei Jahren einen Director of Football, wir haben uns auch da schon mal in einer Rasenfolge unterhalten, also sozusagen einen Sportdirektor zu installieren, der dann mittels Mann ist, das Budget hat, das freigeben kann, um beispielsweise einfach einen sportlichen Plan vorzugeben, in puncto Kaderbau beispielsweise. Den haben sie seit zwei Jahren im Auge, aber es ist nie jemand geworden. Sie haben auch Namen, die grundsätzlich brauchbar gewesen wären, einfach verstreichen lassen. Letztes Beispiel, Beppe Marotta von Juventus Turin, der da als Ingenieur gilt sozusagen, den hat man jetzt Richtung Inter ziehen lassen, obwohl man sich mal mit dem unterhalten hat. Ich weiß nicht, wie nah die da dran waren, aber nur als Beispiel, dass man da einiges versäumt hat. Und es gibt im Grunde genommen keinerlei Struktur, wer was sportlich zu entscheiden hat. Ed Woodward sagt auch relativ offen, es gab im September eine Telefonkonferenz mit potenziellen Investoren, wo er gesagt hat, bitte analysiert jetzt nicht jedes Spiel einzeln, sondern schaut aufs große Bild. Und da hat er mehr oder weniger damit zugegeben, dass der Sport gar nicht so wichtig ist bei Manchester United. Mit dieser einen Ausnahme –und das ist jetzt Jose Mourinho zum Verhängnis geworden –wenn die Champions League-Qualifikation im Zweifel steht, dann würde gehandelt werden. Und das ist jetzt der Fall, weil man kann sich als Manchester United nicht leisten, nicht die ganz große Bühne zu bespielen. Wenn das im Zweifel steht –das ist auch Louis von Kahl zum Verhängnis geworden –dann würde man agieren. Andernfalls würde man das Ganze einfach so weiterlaufen lassen. Also, nochmal ganz kurz. Wir sind in einer Phase, wo David Moyes in seinem ursprünglichen Vertrag als Ferguson Nachfolger noch fünf Monate zu gehen hätte. In der Zwischenzeit hat Ed Woodward drei Trainer verpflichtet, die allesamt nicht gezündet haben. Ich habe mir das nochmal rausgeschrieben im Spiel Liverpool, dass er letztendlich Mourinho zum Verhängnis geworden ist. Sind 14 Spieler eingesetzt, zwölf davon von vier Managern gekauft. Zwei davon aus der eigenen Jugend. Auch das funktioniert vorne und hinten nicht mehr bei Manchester United. Die Jugendmannschaft ist in Division Tour abgestiegen, hat über Jahre hinweg diese Jugendarbeit, das Fundament für einen tollen Profikader gebildet. Man denke an die Class of 92, die 1999 das Triple geholt hat, wo er unserem SoulScare seinen Einfluss darauf hatte. Bayern-Fans werden sich erinnern. Läuft alles nicht. Infrastrukturell läuft nichts. Es ist keiner da, der Entscheidungen vernünftig sportlich einfach tun kann. Wutwort ist es auch relativ egal. Und dann holst du dir mit José Mourinho jemanden ins Boot, wo du wusstest, wenn du ihm die Zügel in die Hand gibst, dann könnte das funktionieren. Gibst du ihm im Januar einen Vertrag bis 2020, verlängerst ihn. Und lässt ihn jetzt für einen Haufen Geld nach nicht mal einem Jahr. Das ist eine Vollkatastrophe und da liegt so viel im Argen, dass wir jetzt den Rasenfunk royal. Draus machen müssen und wir würden noch nicht mal richtig an die Gründe rankommen. Wichtiger als Mourinhos Nachfolger ist die Installation eines Directors of Football. Das ist für mich zentralster Bestandteil. Nehmt Woodward alles weg an Entscheidungskraft Richtung Sport. Lasst ihn sein finanziellen Sachen machen.
Aber sportlich muss jemand anderes her. Wir haben über Mourinhos kurz gesprochen, aber da haben sich auch alle anderen zu geäußert. Da wird auch schon jeder seine Meinung zu haben, ob er Mourinhos glücklich fand in seinem Agieren bei United oder nicht. Interessanterweise gehen daher auch die Spielermannungen ein bisschen auseinander. Jetzt finde ich aber gibt es noch eine zentrale Frage, die ich gerne dir noch stellen wollen würde. Und zwar, wie gut ist eigentlich dieser Kader? Denn wenn ich allein auf das gucke, was man zum Beispiel zur Saison 16, 17 investiert hat und das, was man zur Saison 17, 18 investiert hat, dann sind das ja wahnsinnige Summen. Ein Paul Pogba für über 100 Millionen, Henrik Mkhitaryan, Eric Bayy wurde geholt, Victor Lindelöf, Matic, Lukaku. Das heißt, da steckt ja schon sehr, sehr viel Geld drin und ich habe auch häufiger die Einschätzung von Journalisten aus Großbritannien gelesen, die geschrieben haben, dass das Beste, was der beste Trick, den Mourinho geschafft hätte, wäre, uns zu vermitteln, dass man mit diesem Kader keinen anderen Fußball spielen könne, als den sehr defensiven, den er spielen lassen würde damit. Also wie gut ist denn der zusammengestellte Kader? Was wäre drin?
Es klingt jetzt wieder so, als wäre ich Mourinhos Anwalt, will ich gar nicht sein, aber auch da liegt die Wahrheit von diesen 14 Spielern. Liverpool, 12 gekauft von mir, von vier Managern. Entsprechend stecken da auch vier Absichten drin, stilistischer Art, die Mourinho dann zu vereilen hat. Damit will ich ihn gar nicht in Schutz nehmen, weil die Spieler, die er gekauft hat, waren auch 400 Millionen Pfund schwer und da steckt Weltklasse drin. Oder zumindest, wir alle haben geglaubt, dass Alexis Sánchez funktionieren könnte beispielsweise. Funktioniert vorne und hinten nicht. Im Nachhinein ist es uns auch klar. Ja, er hat auch in der Verteidigung, wo er selbst gesagt hat, er braucht mindestens zwei Spieler, hat er auch bei ihr, hat er auch Lindeleuf geholt, die sich unterschiedlich gut entwickeln. Bei ihr war verletzt. Lindeleuf ist, glaube ich, jemand, der einfach eine Wohlfühloase um sich herum braucht, um zu bestehen. Und dann sind es doch wieder die Alten geworden, die man auch katastrophal mit langen Verträgen ausgestattet hat, wo du manchmal denkst, wieso bindest du jemand Verletzungsanfälligen wie Luke Shaw so lange für so viel Geld. Aber gut, das ist nochmal ein anderes Thema, den auch Mourinho mehrfach abgewatscht hat. Aber na gut, ist halt so. Der Kader ist, glaube ich, schon in der Spitze sehr stark, wenn alle ihre Leistungsfähigkeit abrufen würden. Romelu Lukaku ist todesmüde und wirkte mir zuletzt auch nicht so, als hätte er richtig Bock auf die ganze Nummer. Über die Beziehung Mourinho und Pobar ist unglaublich viel gesprochen worden. Das ist sicherlich auch zum großen Teil überhitzt gewesen. Andererseits hat Pobar ja auch keinen Held daraus gemacht, wenn er mal gesprochen hat, dass er gesagt hat, ich spiele für United und nicht für Mourinho. Der hat auch Teile der Kabine infiziert und es gibt ja auch nicht wenige, die behaupten, dass er so eine Art Geschwür in der Kabine ist. Soweit würde ich nicht gehen. Ich glaube schon auch, dass da beide, sowohl Mourinho mit seinem –ich nenne es mal –Lager, als auch Pobar mit seinem Lager, also das Gefolge an Spielern, die eher in seiner Ecke stehen, da haben sie beide ihren Anteil dran.
Es reicht ja allein schon, dass es Lager gibt. Das sagt ja schon einiges.
Richtig, genau, richtig. Damit weißt du eigentlich schon ganz viel. Ich würde es, um die Frage abschließend zu beantworten, eher auf zwei andere Teams drehen. Guck mal, was bei Manchester City passiert. Da scheint jeder einzelne Move in den anderen zu münden. Also das zahnt und verzahnt sich irgendwann. Du holst einmal Reglaport und sagst, ja klar, genau das muss dahin. Das ist der fehlende Stein, der Manchester City schon mal wenigstens auf nationaler Ebene unschlagbar macht, auch wenn sie jetzt geschlagen wurden, aber auf lange Sicht unschlagbar macht. Manchester United beispielsweise betreibt eine Art Hotshotting. Also dann brennt es wieder und dann holen sie da einen rein und denken, ok, das war's, aber du hast keinen Overall-Plan, den City hat und den auch Liverpool hat. Jede einzelne Verpflichtung Liverpools im Sommer ist zu 100% sinnvoll. Auch wenn viele zu Beginn dachten Fabinho, das könnte der Schlüssel sein, weil ich behaupte, dass Jordan Henderson nicht der Schlüssel ist. Auch wenn er der Kapitän ist und sicherlich immer ein bisschen arg unterbewertet wird, Fabinho anstelle Handisons könnte funktionieren. Dann fehlt ja immer noch der kreative Teil, vielleicht kann das Navicator irgendwann mal tun, wie auch immer. Aber rein prinzipiell kann ich alles verstehen, was Liverpool da tut, und das folgt alles dieser einen Logik, die von einem vorgegeben wird, Jürgen Klopp. Bei City ist es genau das Gleiche. Und bei Manchester United habe ich das Gefühl, Mourinho hat schon seine Logik, jetzt kann man diskutieren darüber, ist seine Systematik prinzipiell noch der Moderne zuträglich, aber er hat seine Logik, aber er bekam nicht die Spieler, die er wollte. Und dann kannst du ihn auch nur teilweise daran messen. Noch mal, keine Verteidigung Mourinhos. Der Kader ist immer noch teuer, ja, aber das ist mir ein bisschen zu leicht, jetzt zu sagen, nur weil die teuer sind, passt das alles ineinander. Er hat zentrale Teile seiner Idee nicht bekommen. Pericic ist das allerbeste Beispiel in 2017, wo er gesagt hat, uns fehlt es an einem Außenspieler. Die meisten Spiele in dieser Spielzeit auf der rechten Außenbahn hat Juan Mata gemacht, der kein Tempo für diese Position besitzt. Ich glaube nicht, auch wenn Rushford teilweise gespielt hat, ich glaube nicht, dass das richtig ist. Er gehört ins Zentrum nach wie vor, meiner Meinung nach. Gut, kann man sagen, mit Marcel auf links, mit Rushford auf rechts hätte er das benötigte Tempo gehabt. Ich glaube einfach nicht, dass das passt. Kader ist gut, aber Kader ist der drittbeste in der Premier League. Das ist das, woran Mourinho hätte gemessen werden müssen, dass er Platz 3 schafft, nicht aber 1 und 2. Die sind besetzt, auch wenn ich das, das gebe ich offen zu, im Sommer so nicht antizipiert hatte. Ich habe United vor Liverpool gehabt, aber im Nachhinein muss man schon draufkommen, dass Liverpools Kader vielleicht nicht ganz so breit ist, aber in der Spitze passender einfach ist. Und das ist, glaube ich, der Punkt. Da geht man in eine Richtung, und bei United gibt es mindestens mal zwei Richtungen.
Ja, das hast du sehr schön herausgearbeitet und drückt sich dann der Tabelle jetzt zwischenzeitlich mit dem sechsten Tabellenplatz aus und 11 Punkten Rückstand auf den ersten Champions League-Platz und gar 19 Punkte Rückstand auf Tabellenplatz 1, um den es ja dann vielleicht gar nicht mehr so wirklich geht. Was aber genau den Blick dahin richtet, Uli? Denn da grüßt der FC Liverpool mit der besten Bilanz seine Historie immer noch ungeschlagen nach 17 Spieltagen. 37 zu 7 Tore, 45 Punkte. Ich kann mich aber erinnern, dass da in dieser Saison schon einige engere Spiele mit dabei waren. Nicht zuletzt gegen Everton mit dieser Slapstick-Nummer von Pickford, wo dann ein geschenktes Tor zum 1-0 geführt hat. Würdest du sagen, die Dominanz, die wir in der Tabelle sehen von Liverpool, die entspricht auch dem, was man auf dem Feld sieht? Oder fällt da gerade alles so ein bisschen zu Gunsten von Liverpool in der Liga aus?
Also ich muss mich minimal verbessern, weil wenn schon, dann gehen Liverpool und Manchester City vorne rein. Ich glaube, die haben mich nicht überzeugt, und das überzeugt mich am meisten. Die sind spielerisch gerade auf einem Level, wo ich sage, ja, okay, sie gewinnen Spiele, aber sie sind durchaus ein bisschen platt. Das selbe gilt aber auch für Manchester City.
Was meinst du mit platt? Meinst du das physisch oder meinst du das von der mentalen Perspektive?
Bestimmt auch. Da gibt es ja auch sogar Stimmen aus der Mannschaft. Lovren, Vizeweltmeister, mit Kroatien geworden, der gesagt hat, das ist völlig logisch, ich hatte genau drei Wochen Zeit, um von der Weltmeisterschaft hin zum Trainingscamp zu kommen. Das ist völlig normal, dass wir gar nicht auf der Höhe sein können. Bei Salah hat es Jürgen Klopp ja auch zugegeben, dass es sowohl körperlich als auch mental nicht ganz hundertprozentig auf der Höhe war. Aber das ist das, was wir haben dann häufig in den Übertragungen gesagt, sie spielen ein bisschen pragmatischer in dieser Saison. Und dasselbe gilt auch für Manchester City. Das ist nicht mehr Free Flow, sondern das ist alles ein bisschen sachlicher. Ich glaube aber, dass das auch ein bisschen gezwungener Maße ist. Aber das ist gleichzeitig das, was ich bei Liverpool in den letzten Jahren nicht erkannt habe. Haben die schwach gespielt, haben sie die Ergebnisse nicht geholt? Auf hohem Niveau, aber sie haben sie nicht geholt. In dieser Saison holen sie sie. Und das ist der größte Vorteil. Und das überzeugt mich am allermeisten. Sodass ich denke, ja, vieles läuft für Liverpool. Ich meine, insofern, weil Manchester City jüngst jetzt gestern Abend in den EFL-Cup spielen mussten, wenn auch mit der zweiten Mannschaft, aber die haben noch ein bisschen mehr zu tun als Liverpool, die in diesem Wettbewerb schon ausgeschieden sind. City hat sich jetzt einmal ausnahmsweise die Blöße gegeben gegen Chelsea, da verloren. Insofern läuft vieles für Liverpool, ja. Aber die haben in der Champions League einen schwierigeren Gegner jetzt. Ich glaube, das gleicht sich dann schon irgendwie aus. Die sind einfach im Moment zu Recht an der Spitze, weil sie die Defensive abgedichtet haben. Das ist, muss man echt sagen, eine große Leistung, der ich auch noch immer nicht zu 100 Prozent traue, weil sie manchmal mit alles sonst irren Paraden das Ergebnis geschönt haben. Dafür ist er da, klar. Aber ich will sehen, unter längerem Druck, wenn sie wirklich auch mal wieder Verletzungsprobleme bekommen sollten, dann will ich sehen, wie sie wirklich da sind für den Moment. Ist das eine richtig gute Saison? Ohne, dass sie mich jetzt wirklich vom Hocker hauen. Aber das ist vielleicht sogar das Beste, was man über Liverpool derzeit sagen kann.
Und wie hoch würdest du es hängen, dass es auswärts, vor allem in der Champions League, jetzt manchmal nicht so gut funktioniert hat bei Liverpool? Also sowohl in Neapel verloren, als auch in Belgrad verloren und in Paris verloren. Ist das jetzt einfach drei Einzel-Events, die ich jetzt gerade in einen Topf schmeiße? Oder würdest du da schon einen Muster drin erkennen?
Nein, es war auch letzte Saison so, dass sie auswärts vor allen Dingen die Defensive nicht so sehr im Griff hatten. Also das ist, glaube ich, schon auch eine Storyline, die man sich zumindest mal markieren sollte, wo man immer mal wieder nachschauen kann. In der Premier League allerdings holen sie die Ergebnisse sehr, sehr gut. Und das ist genau das, was ich aber meinte. In der vergangenen Spielzeit haben sie gerade gegen oder auch in den vergangenen Spielzeiten unter Klopp haben sie gerade gegen die kleineren Gegner einfach mal immer mal wieder kein Ergebnis geholt, haben sogar verloren. Da würde ich das Belgraht-Spiel jetzt reinrechnen. Paris ist eine Weltklasse-Mannschaft, hands down, und die hat das an diesem Abend sehr gut verteidigt. Das war einfach stark und Liverpool war insgesamt die bessere Mannschaft, was jetzt so Spielanteile betrifft, aber da sind sie nicht durchgekommen. Und Neapel, das war in diesem Fall einfach klassisch ausgecoacht. Ich glaube, jedes Spiel erzählt seine eigene Geschichte, aber prinzipiell ist es schon auch trotzdem was, was ich im Auge behalte, Liverpool auswärts nicht immer stark gewesen, in dieser Saison aber stark verbessert. Und das ist das, worauf ich hinaus möchte, die Abwehr stark verbessert, auch auswärts, und vor allen Dingen, sie kriegen trotzdem dann die Ergebnisse, weil unterm Strich, okay, gut, jetzt hast du drei Mal vielleicht auswärts in der Champions League verloren, du bist aber weiter, und das ist schon mal stark.
Absolut, und jetzt gucke ich mir den Spielplan von Liverpool an, und dann sehe ich, dieses Jahr gibt es ja noch die Winterpause noch nicht, es geht jetzt fröhlich weiter, 21. Dezember, 26. Dezember, 29. Dezember, 3. Januar, können wir uns alle darauf freuen, das Auswärtsspiel bei Manchester City, und dann geht das so fröhlich weiter, bis man dann am 13. Februar gegen Bayern das Hinspiel hat und direkt eine Woche danach, ohne ein Spiel dazwischen, das Rückspiel gegen Bayern. Wie wurde denn die Auslosung in Großbritannien wahrgenommen, in England, und was glaubst du, kann man da jetzt überhaupt jetzt schon seriöse Aussagen treffen, oder ist das nicht alles noch viel zu weit weg, um zu sagen, wer da jetzt klarer Favorit ist?
Ja, das ist schon schwer. Also die öffentlichen Meinungen in Großbritannien, Zeitungen etc., die haben eine unglaublich hohe Meinung von Bayern München, das sind die German Giants, und die wissen schon, dass mit Bayern München, auch wenn es gerade nicht so läuft, immer zu rechnen ist. Klopp selbst war ja bemüht, darum zu sagen, wir freuen uns nicht auf Bayern, sondern auch wir wissen, dass die jederzeit in Lagen sind, Dinge zu tun. Ich glaube schon noch, also Liverpool selbst könnte man schon einschätzen. Das würde ich mir zutrauen. Bei Bayern bin ich mir da noch nicht so ganz sicher, was da jetzt nicht noch passiert bis dahin. Nichtsdestotrotz, auch da, selbe Geschichte, die ich mir durchziehe. Ich habe in der Redaktion auch die letzten Tage, logischerweise war das Thema und wir sind uns immer mal wieder begegnet. Du hast ja in Deutschland dann typischerweise doch den einen oder anderen, der im FC Bayern zugetan ist. Und ich wiederum soll es geben. Und ich wiederum bin dann ja eher in England zu Hause. Und dann hat man mich so gefragt, und was denkst du? Ich vertraue Liverpool noch nicht. Also wenn ich müsste, würde ich nicht alles auf Liverpool setzen. Weil ich schon denke, dass Bayern München abgezockt genug ist, auch wenn es gerade überhaupt nicht läuft. Aber ich glaube das. Und ich vertraue Liverpool nicht immer zu 100 Prozent. Vielleicht ist das ein großer Fehler, aber das Duell ist, glaube ich, offener, als es uns die aktuellen sportlichen Lagen erzählen würden. Einfach weil Liverpool in ganz großen Spielen –jetzt ist das nur das Achtelfinale –aber in ganz großen Spielen nicht immer on point ist. Und weil Bayern in ganz großen Spielen häufig eben schon genau da ist. Deswegen halte ich es viel enger, als viele gerade denken. Aber kann auch sein, dass Liverpool an der Anfield Road einfach 30 Minuten hat, wo sie Bayern überrennen und dann steht es 3-0.
So hat man ja auch schon City in der letzten Champions League-Saison aus dem Wettbewerb genommen. Wir alle können uns, auch wenn es schwerfällt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wir können nochmal durchatmen. Das ist Mitte Februar, bis dahin wird noch ganz viel passieren. Dann schauen wir uns das ganz gut an. Wir registrieren, aber Uli Hebel tut sich sehr schwer, damit Liverpool zu vertrauen. Das hast du das letzte Mal, und ich glaube, das war am 4. Spieltag, oder so was, das wir gesprochen haben, also auf jeden Fall schon eine ganze Weile her, da hast du auch schon immer gesagt, ich traue Liverpool noch nicht so ganz, ich bin mit an euch ganz sicher, das möchte ich mir noch angucken. Und ich finde das aber gut. Zum einen, weil sich das auch in den einzelnen Spielen gezeigt hat und auch in solchen statistischen Spielereihen wie den Expected Goals sieht man zum Beispiel genau das, was du gesagt hast, dass Liverpool eigentlich mehr Gegentore haben müsste. Und da ist Erlisten einer der wesentlichen Gründe, warum sie die nicht haben. Das kann natürlich die ganze Saison so weitergehen, es kann aber schon auch, es ist im Bereich des Denkbaren, dass sich das wieder ein bisschen einpendelt und dann wäre ehrlicherweise Manchester City noch ein bisschen deutlicher weg, wenn das passieren würde. Und zum anderen mag ich das ganz gerne, dass man nicht immer gleich auf jeden Hype draufspringt, weil wir haben es schon häufig genug erlebt, so Spielzeiten sind sehr lange und Liverpool bräuchte nur in Anführungszeichen jetzt eine Ermattungsphase irgendwann ums Jahr oder wann auch immer die käme. Dann spielst du dreimal, viermal unentschieden oder verlierst auch mal und dann gestaltet sich das in der Liga nämlich ganz anders, was ja vor allem auch an dem zweiten Team liegt, über das du auch schon kurz gesprochen hast. Manchester City ist ja das zweite sehr dominante Team und das ist ja das eigentlich Unfassbare, dass Liverpool eine so gute Saison spielt von den Ergebnissen her. 14 Siege, 3 Unentschieden in der Liga, 45 Punkte. Und ein Pünktchen dahinter ist der Verfolger. Manchester City mit 14 Siegen, 2 Unentschieden und einer Niederlage, die war gegen Chelsea. Und jetzt darfst du uns erzählen, wie sehr Vertrauen du in Manchester City hast, dass das so weitergeht unter Pep Guardiola.
Also man muss natürlich dazu sagen, auch City hat Ermattungsphasen, typischerweise nur in der Regel im anderen Wettbewerb. Also nicht in der Liga, sondern in der Champions League dann, was er dann Liverpool nicht hatte.
Vor allem im Frühling wahrscheinlich, gell?
Genau, vor allen Dingen im Frühling. Und so gesehen vertraue ich Manchester City auch nur in diesem einen Wettbewerb.
Du bist ein misstrauischer Mensch.
Ja, aber da vertraue ich ihn dann tatsächlich dafür. Nee, auch bei Manchester City ist es tatsächlich komisch, weil auch die letzten Wochen nicht mehr diese Bank –also in 17, 18, wenn ich die im Dienstplan gesehen habe, habe ich mir immer gedacht, yes, fünf bis sechs Tore, schöner Offensivfußball, da siehst du mindestens einen Geniestreich und wahrscheinlich drei, die du dann in der zweiten Zeitlupe erkennst, wo du denkst, mein Gott, du hast deine Annahme schön weitergespielt, alles ist so in sich passend und für sich gemacht. Nur in dieser Saison ist es auch da so, die sind müder, die machen nicht so viel Spaß, auch wenn es ganz viele so, sagen wir mal, Advanced-Stats, also Statistiken, die etwas weitergehen als pure Passquote, also was dann etwas qualitativ tiefer reingeht, da sind sie noch besser geworden. Zweikampfführung besser, aggressiver, brauchen nicht mehr so lange, also das ist ja sowieso nicht lange, aber bis sie den Ball wiederbekommen nach Ballverlust. Sie sind noch aggressiver geworden, wenn sie den Ball nicht haben, bis sie mal einen Foul spielen. Das ist so die dunkle Macht des Fußballs, aber das gehört ja auch dazu, dass du sozusagen dann auch eine Aggression zeigst, die vielleicht nicht innerhalb der Regel ist, aber du möchtest unbedingt das Spiel, den Rhythmus des Gegners brechen und stoppen. Da sind sie viel besser geworden als im letzten Jahr. Sie haben mit Riyad Mahrez jemanden dazu bekommen, der, glaube ich, die Mannschaft wirklich komplettiert, der auf der rechten Seite spielt, aber viel mehr als ein Außenstürmer ist, sondern viel mehr ein verkappter Spielmacher noch ist. Dann musstest du Stirling von rechts nach links rüber schicken. Das ist problemlos von starten gegangen. Der geht einfach mit dem schwachen Fuß genauso auf Torreakt wie mit dem guten Fuß. Dann hast du ja sogar noch im Überfluss, lieber Sane, den schwachen Start in dieser Saison inzwischen in richtig guter Verfassung ist.
Herr Wende Bräune ist jetzt zurück. Das vergisst man doch so ein bisschen. Der war ja weiteträglich im Netz.
Den hat man gar nicht vermisst, was auch irre ist, weil Bernardo Silva noch mal einen großen Schritt gemacht hat. Also kaum jemand hat über Bernardo Silva gesprochen, weil Bernardo Silva das einfach so nebenbei mitmacht. Und trotzdem sind die Ergebnisse da. Also insgesamt ist die Prognose schon eine recht positive, wenn man sich alle Zahlen anschaut, wenn man sich insgesamt die Ergebnisse anguckt. Dieses eine Lyon-Spiel in der Champions League, erstes Heimspiel, wo sie verloren haben, überraschenderweise, das hat mich schon denken lassen. Und jetzt haben sie halt gegen Chelsea tatsächlich es mal geschafft, aus dem vielen Ballbesitz nichts zu machen, nämlich nicht mal einen Torschuss zu produzieren. Und das ist dann wiederum das andere. Guardiola ist so sehr auf seinen Plan fixiert und den kriegen sie ganz gut durch. Aber in Spielen, wo er dann denkt, das ist jetzt auch ein Trainer-Spiel, da will er dann ganz gerne den Kniff zeigen, der alles verändert. Und das ist häufig genau das Negative dabei. Deswegen, wenn ich einen Trainer auswählen müsste, dem ich sozusagen die Schlüssel in die Hand geben würde, würde ich sagen, Pep Guardiola, nimm und mach. Ich vertraue dir. Aber ich bin ein misstrauischer Mensch. Ich vertraue ihm auch noch nicht bis ins Letzte. Und das wird interessant. Also das Spiel am, ich glaube, 3. Januar, Liverpool, City in der Premier League, da werden wir vieles lernen. Da freue ich mich wirklich sehr drauf. Da werden wir ganz, ganz, ganz viel lernen über diese Manchester-City-Mannschaft, der ich prinzipiell immer noch leicht einfach den Vorzug geben würde gegenüber Liverpool, weil ich einfach glaube, dass sie insgesamt kompletter sind. Bei Liverpool habe ich so ein paar Sorgen, was das Zentrum betrifft. Also da ist einfach echt viel machbar. Und Manchester City ist, glaube ich, noch kompletter. Sie haben auch den etwas breiteren Kader noch. Also da so eine Verletzung wie de Bruynes, die fällt gar nicht groß ins Gewicht. Die haben sowieso gerade ein paar Verletzungs-Sorgen, die gar nicht so groß ins Gewicht fallen, weil sie halt einfach einen Aguero mit einem Jesus austauschen können, weil sie eben beispielsweise Maris und Stirling mit Sané austauschen könnten, weil de Bruyne durch Bernardo Silva ersetzt wird und, und, und.
Und wir machen das mit Mendy auf links, weil Links-Verteidiger ist ja immer auch im System. Guardiola sind die Außenverteidiger durchaus sehr, sehr wichtig.
Richtig, da wird möglicherweise auch sogar was passieren im Januar. Also Mendy ist ein guter Mann, aber ich sage eine Sache, wenn du mit Sané auf links spielst, ist es besser, wenn Mendy nicht dabei ist, weil der zieht durch zur Grundlinie und Sané muss dann ins Zentrum rutschen. Und damit ist er nicht mehr so effektiv. Bedeutet, ein Sané gefällt mir viel besser ohne Mendy mit Delph, der genau eher das tut, dass der nämlich ins Zentrum rückt oder auch Senchenko, der ausschließlich fast seine Zeit im Zentrum verbringt. Fluch und Segen sozusagen. Aber es gibt da schon Tendenzen, dass man –und das ist, wenn man eins gelernt hat aus dieser Doku über Manchester City, die sie ja letzte Saison über weite Strecken auch begleitet hat, dass das Trainerteam immer wieder nur teilglücklich war, weil ihnen der perfekte Innenverteidiger abging, den sie dann im Januar mit Laporte zugefügt haben. Dann weiß man auch, glaube ich, dass die wirklich überlegen, ob es nicht irgendwo da draußen einen Linksfuß gibt, der sich in die Viererkette stellen würde, der sie dann hundertprozentig glücklich macht. Da wird immer mal wieder Chillboy genannt von Leicester, auch wenn Guardiola das jetzt erst mal abgestritten hat. Aber das wäre eine Position, wo ich denken würde, dass sie sich schon noch einen verlässlichen Back-up holen, weil Mendy jetzt ja schon nachgewiesen hat, dass er verletzungsanfällig ist.
Okay, interessant. Dann lass noch mal weitergehen in der Tabelle. Über die Spurs müssen wir auf jeden Fall noch mal reden, unter anderem ja auch wegen der Champions League-Auslosung gegen Borussia Dortmund. Interessieren wir als Deutsche uns da ja besonders für. Die Spurs haben 13 Mal gewonnen, kein Unentschieden. Dafür schon vier Niederlagen. Damit kommt man dann bei fünf Punkten Rückstand auf City und sechs Punkten Rückstand auf Liverpool auf den dritten Tabellenplatz rein. Und du hast vorhin aber schon Pochettino lobend erwähnt. Woher kommt diese Zuneigung?
Weil ich glaube, dass er alles tut, was Manchester United früher mal stark gemacht hat. Nämlich einen klaren Plan verfolgen, durchaus gerne auf hausgemachte Spieler setzt und wirklich eine Durchlässigkeit schafft ins erste Team. Und damit Spieler wie Kane überhaupt erst möglich macht, der eigentlich ja schon im englischen System fast verloren war, weil ausgeliehen und niemand hat mehr an ihn geglaubt. Irgendwann gibt er ihm die Möglichkeit zu spielen. Daley Alli selbes Spiel, Harry Wink selbes Spiel. Und so bringt er immer wieder eine Erfrischung in die Mannschaft, auch wenn es keinen großen Transfer im Sommer gab. Die ist auch wieder da. Prinzipiell ist Mauricio Pochettino jemand, der ebenfalls einen klaren Plan verfolgt, der, wie ich finde, nicht überschwänglich positiv, aber authentisch nach außen auftritt. Und dieses Team tatsächlich sukzessive weiterbringt, es auch schafft, die Spieler für seinen Plan zu begeistern. Anders wäre es nicht zu erklären, dass alle Spieler wieder verlängert haben und wirklich noch mal den nächsten Schritt gehen, auch wenn es wieder keinen Silber gab jetzt im Sommer. Die hätten es sich alle leicht machen können, Delhi early Richtung Manchester, City, United, Liverpool abzuziehen. Die hätten ihn sicherlich alle gerne genommen. Da hätte es auch noch zwei, drei Mannschaften aus Spanien gegeben, die wahrscheinlich ganz gerne gesagt hätten, jo, machen wir, Harry Kane, brauchen wir nicht drüber reden sowieso. Aber er begeistert sie alle für diesen Plan und er stellt ihnen eine Aussicht, dass das gemeinsam irgendwann klappen könnte. Deswegen denke ich auch, dass Pochettino jetzt nicht das Schiff verlässt, um sich United anzuschließen. Der hat im Sommer Real Madrid abgesagt. Und das war wahrscheinlich der antizipiert größere Job, wenn man mal global das Ganze sieht. Also glaube ich einfach nicht. Aber vielleicht gibt es da auch Überredungskünste mit ein paar Nullen hinten dran, die vielleicht ihn umdenken ließen. Aber im Moment glaube ich dran, dass er auch dran glaubt, dass was geht bei Tottenham, die immer wieder in Lauer-Stellung sind. Ähnlicher Befund wie bei den erst genannten beiden Teams. Das sieht teilweise ein bisschen welk aus. Was da so auf dem Platz passiert, das kannst du an Einzelschicksalen erkennen. Lukas Moura überraschenderweise im August losgelegt. Wie verrückt. Den hat er wirklich jede einzelne Minute rausgequetscht. Und der wirkt immer unfrischer. Also der, sagen wir mal, wird schwächer von Spiel zu Spiel in Sachen Körperlichkeit beispielsweise. Aber breiter Kader, extrem breiter Kader, den Tottenham zur Verfügung hat. Auch da würde ich immer noch denken, da fehlt immer noch der eine, der, wenn es mal nicht läuft, vorangeht, das ist sehr platt, aber ich traue keinem zu, dass wirklich mal so ein richtiger Führungsspieler da ist. So einer, der auch intern mal das Ding in die Hand nimmt, wenn es gerade mal nicht so läuft. Harry Kane ist zwar der Kapitän, aber ist für mich jetzt nicht der Typ Lautsprecher in dem Sinne. Das ist das einzige, was mir tatsächlich so ein bisschen fehlt bei Tottenham. Das sind ganz viele ganz ruhige, ganz gut erzorgene, höfliche Typen, Superfußballer, haben einen Supertrainer, der aber auch jetzt nicht derjenige ist, der wirklich dann, also kann ich mir zumindest nicht vorstellen, aggressiv nach innen auftritt und mal wirklich fordert, sondern der insgesamt noch, das kann noch kommen, der ist auch noch als Trainer recht jung mit 46, aber der noch mehr einfordert, dass jetzt ist das Fenster offen, jetzt sind die in dieser Altersstruktur, jetzt müssen die gewinnen oder zumindest anfangen, sich damit auseinanderzusetzen und deswegen auch da habe ich ein gewisses Misstrauen.
Und ist das Tottenhemm, was wir aktuell sehen, auch das Tottenhemm, dass wir noch eine Erinnerung haben von den früheren Begegnungen mit Borussia Dortmund, also das wird ja langsam zu so einer Bayern Arsenal-Nummer, das heißt, man sieht sich in jedem Jahr im internationalen Wettbewerb irgendwie dann auch egal, in welchem hat sich da was verändert zu den vorherigen Begegnungen im Spielstil in der Form?
Nee, in weiten Teilen ist das ähnlich mit dem Unterschied, dass sich die Schlüsselspiele bei Tottenham schon ganz gut entwickelt haben. Also Christian Eriksen hat große Schritte gemacht seither, Harry Kane hat große Schritte gemacht seither, Dali Alli ist reifer geworden, aber im Grunde genommen ist das System Tottenham das Gleiche geblieben, was auch in England durchaus Pochettino vorgeworfen wird, dass es diesen einen Trick gibt und eben keinen anderen. Aber finde ich auch völlig okay, wenn du an deine Sache glaubst und die einzelnen Spieler sich immer noch weiterentwickeln und wenn du irgendwann mal jemanden tauschst, weil du einfach Altersgründe hast oder weil du irgendwie siehst, okay, der oder der ist besser, dann kann man das gerne machen. Insgesamt hat sich vielleicht ein bisschen was verändert durch die Reinnahme Lucas Mouras, der jetzt einfach mehr Spielzeit bekommt, der nochmal ein anderer Typ ist, der viel mit Drehungen arbeitet, wuslich ist. Aber das ist eigentlich nur der Typ, der die Position sozusagen anders interpretiert, aber rein prinzipiell hat sich an der Systematik ganz wenig verändert.
Und wirklich interessanter Aspekt bei diesen Champions League-Partien, die Premier League-Vereine, also Liverpool und Tottenham, die haben jeweils eine Woche frei zwischen beiden Partien, kein Spiel am Wochenende. Die Bundesliga-Vereine müssen jeweils antreten, also der FC Bayern wird in Augsburg spielen, zwischen den Liverpool-Spielen, und Borussia Dortmund wird gegen Nürnberg spielen, zwischen den Tottenham-Spielen. Das ist dann vielleicht noch ein ganz interessanter Faktor, aber da kümmern wir uns im Februar ganz ins Ruhe drüber. Kommt wieder runter, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das ist noch eine Weile hin, bis wir diese tollen Champions League-Achtelfinals sehen dürfen. Lass uns noch über zwei Mannschaften wenigstens kurz sprechen, weil es würde mich auch sehr interessieren, was sich da getan hat. Zunächst den FC Chelsea, der mit 37 Punkten auf Platz 4 liegt, aktuell auch erst zweimal verloren hat. Da haben wir ganz lange auf die erste Niederlage gewartet und uns gefragt, wann ist es soweit? Wie würdest du die bewerten? Die scheinen mir sehr stabil zu sein in dem, was sie liefern.
Absolut. Also das ist für mich die Geschichte der Saison bislang. Wahnsinn, wenn man sich vor allen Dingen ansieht, woher die kommen aus einem zerrütteten Verhältnis, Trainer, Mannschaft, Vorstand. Auch da ist es, glaube ich, ein ähnlicher Befund im Grunde, wie bei Manchester United. Das passt vorne und hinten nicht. Aber trotzdem ist da mit Sarri jetzt jemand, der einfach sein Ding macht und der macht es sehr gut. Und die sind erstaunlich schnell rangekommen an das, was er von ihnen möchte. Ganz interessante Varianten. Der bildet im Mittelfeld so Pärchen. Also es spielt immer Jorginho oder Fabregas. Nicht beide gemeinsam. Das ist eine Position, die doppelt besetzt ist. Und genauso zieht er sein Spielsystem auf. Jeder weiß genau, was er zu tun hat. Ednazar ist ausgezeichnet drauf. Pedro ist wieder der alte Pedro. Der ist wieder aggressiv gegen den Ball, ist auch plötzlich wieder als Abschlussspieler da. Schöne Geschichte. Ich mag Chelsea gerne. Die haben wieder Spaß. Das sieht man auch wirklich an so Spielen wie gegen Brighton am Sonntag. Das sind Unterkontenummern gewesen, wo du gerade in seiner Nachmeisterschaftssaison um Himmels willen dachte, da haben die gar keine Lust auf diesen Betriebsausflug. Nee, wir fahren dahin, haben Spaß, spielen Fußball, haben viel Ballbesitz. Auch da ist noch für mich die Frage, wenn sich da mal ein paar verletzen würden, also die Schlüsselspieler namentlich eben, also vielleicht auch Kante, vielleicht auch Jorginho. Im Altersschnitt ist Chelsea relativ alt, da muss jetzt auch ein Transit weiter hin her. Aber insgesamt, ich glaube, das hätte man zu 100 Prozent so unterschrieben, wenn man vor der Spielzeit gesagt hätte, Chelsea ist so stark in der Liga. Weil auch da müssen wir ehrlich wieder sagen, 17 Spiele, 37 Punkte. Wären da nicht Liverpool und City so irre, dann wären die ganz nah dran an den Meisterschaftsringen. So glaubt halt niemand daran, spricht niemand davon. Aber das ist gut. Also Chelsea entwickelt sich einfach gut. Sarri, bitte unbedingt weitermachen lassen. Seine Wünsche erfüllen auf den Transfermärkten. Ich hoffe, das habe ich auch schon, glaube ich, hundertmal erzählt, auch hier im Rasenfunk. Ich wünsche mir trotzdem, dass Chelsea eine unglaubliche Jugendarbeit hat. Ich wünsche mir trotzdem, dass Sarri da irgendwann ein paar Leute durchlässt, dass sie jetzt nicht wieder Harzen und Neudeu verkaufen, was ein großer Fehler wäre, sondern bitte einbauen. Die haben gute Leute. Das würde ich mir einfach so persönlich wünschen, weil dann glaube ich auch, dass Chelsea etwas nachhaltiger arbeiten könnte und nicht immer nur in diesen zwei Spielzeitabschnitten denken, so wie sie es unter Konter gemacht haben, weil typischerweise gute Saison Sarri und nächstes Jahr implodiert wieder alles. Das würde ich mir einfach wünschen. Stabilität und weniger Einmischung von oben, sondern lasst mal Maurizio Sarri machen. Das scheint nämlich ein sehr guter Mann zu sein.
Wahnsinn, da gerätst du ja richtig ins Schwärmen. Jetzt haben wir ja mit Pochettino, Jürgen Klopp, Pep Guardiola und jetzt mit Sarri jede Menge Trainer, die von außen in die Premier League reinkommen und dann so schnell so viel Erfolg haben. Hat das denn auch so ein bisschen die Art und Weise verändert, wie man über solche Trainer spricht und denkt in der Premier League?
Ich glaube, das kann man wirklich auch festmachen. Das ist jetzt einfach nur ein aktuelles Beispiel, wo Manchester United früher darüber nachgedacht hätte, Ian Eddie Howe zu verpflichten, also den quasi britischen Trainer aus der Premier League zu denken. Sie heute nicht mal im Ansatz darüber nach, ob es jemanden mit britischem Pass gäbe. Im Gegenteil, sie schauen ausschließlich nach außen. Ich glaube auch, Ralf Hasenhoetl hat ja auch sein erstes Spiel bei Southampton gewonnen am Wochenende, erstes Heimspiel. Ich glaube vor allen Dingen, das könnte zum Trend werden, diese taktischen Pressing-Trainer aus Deutschland oder aus dem deutschsprachigen Raum, um es mal zu erweitern. Wenn das jetzt noch einmal funktioniert bei Southampton, die nennen den ja eh schon den Alpenklub, haben die großen Spaß daran, dass diesen Spitzen damit irgendwo mal gab, das finde ich ganz witzig, dann könnte ich mir vorstellen, dass die Nächsten in dieser Runde, die, weiß ich nicht, auch wenn es jetzt ein anderer Typ ist, aber die Tedescos sind, vielleicht sogar irgendwann mal die Manuel Baums, die Nagelsmanns, die dann irgendwann mal da so angedacht werden. Kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen. Insofern, ja, die Premier League lässt sich da extrem beeinflussen. Das ist auch so ganz viel Copy und Paste, also die kleineren Vereine versuchen, die größeren zu kopieren und jeder sucht den zweiten Klopp, jeder sucht den zweiten Guardiola. Und das siehst du auch extrem an der Art und Weise, wie da die Trainer inzwischen gescoutet werden, hat sich außerordentlich verändert.
Faszinierend. Und das ist vielleicht auch der größte Unterschied zwischen der Premier League und Karl-Heinz Rummenigge. Die einen machen Copy und Paste, die anderen Paste und Copy. Was davon dann effizienter ist, das darf jeder mal selbst bei sich am heimischen Computer ausprobieren. Lass uns noch kurz zumindest über Arsenal sprechen. Da kommen immer wieder Meldungen rübergeschwappt, wenn irgendetwas mit Meso und Özil passiert. Insgesamt kann man aber sagen, Arsenal gehört jetzt zu diesem Fünfer-Pack vorne drin und hat einen deutlichen Vorsprung auf Manchester United auf Platz sechs. Wie zufrieden ist man denn mit der aktuellen Tabellensituation?
Und das ist auch total richtig. Wir haben vor der Saison gesagt, wenn sie die Top sechs schaffen, ist alles gut. Sie sind jetzt mehr oder weniger zementiert auf der Fünf, sind weiter in der Europa League und der Emery, glaube ich, kennt sich da ein bisschen aus in dem Wettbewerb. Also würde mich auch nicht wundern, wenn er das, glaube ich, brauchbares Los mit Borisov erwischt, wenn das da weitgehen könnte. Sind jetzt das erste Mal wieder nicht zielreich vom Platz gegangen nach 22 Spielen. Das im Dezember 2018, nachdem Wenger 400 Jahre im Amt war. Wer hat das geglaubt? Ganz stark. Auch da ist nicht alles hundertprozentig gut, was die machen. Das ist nicht immer super spielerischer Art, aber genau das war ja das, was wir bemängelt hatten in den vergangenen Jahren. Spielerisch war immer alles schön, aber gewonnen haben sie nie. Jetzt haben sie die ganze Zeit über gewonnen. Obwohl sie nicht immer hundertprozentig gut gespielt haben, haben sie sich im Sommer, was man jetzt im Nachhinein weiß, richtig gut verstärkt. Torreira ist ein Monster. Mit Gendouzi haben sie einen 19-Jährigen geholt, der mir super gefällt, der natürlich vieles lernen muss, wahnsinnig roh ist, aber das wird einer. Das ist schon einer. Das ist auch so ein Typ, den du brauchen kannst, weil der super positiv ist in seiner gesamten Herangehensweise. Sehr mutig. Du hast Aubameyang nochmal neue Dinge eingehaucht. Du hast mit Lacassette jemanden, der gerade ein bisschen schwächelt, der aber auch den nächsten Schritt gemacht hat. Es gibt nach wie vor Probleme in der Verteidigung. Auch David Zoukratis, glaube ich, immer schlechter gemacht, als er wirklich ist. Er kann ganz wenig dafür, häufig. Das ist einfach so dem Spielsystem geschuldet. Aber sie haben gelernt, Pressing zu spielen. Herzlichen Glückwunsch in 2008. Das ist gut und das tut Arsenal gut. Da ist meine Prognose wirklich vor allen Dingen im Vergleich mit dem, wo sie herkommen, 100 Prozent positiv. Es ist eine starke Entwicklung, die Arsenal genommen hat. Platz 5 ist auch da. 34 Punkte nach 17 Spielen. Da wärst du noch in der Konversation. Top 2, Top 3 in der normalen Saison. Aber Liverpool und City sind geisteskrank. Daher ist es nicht so. Aber insgesamt alles sehr gut. Auch da, genauso wie bei Chelsea, dass die zu diesem Zeitpunkt des Transits schon so weit sind, ist richtig gut. Der Einzige, für den das halt blöd läuft, ist halt Mesut Özil.
Und kann man festmachen, warum? Er hatte ja zum Teil Rückenprobleme, deswegen hat er ein paar Spiele verpasst. Er war zwischenzeitlich Kapitän und hat dann auch ein paar Spiele in Serie wiedergemacht. Insgesamt aber hat er eine unruhige Saison. Ihm fehlt jetzt quasi die Teilhabe an vielen der Spiele. Und jetzt ging es auch, dass Hampton zum Beispiel nur 20 Minuten gespielt ist, auch nach seiner Verletzung. Wie würdest du die Situation von ihm einschätzen?
Ja, vor allen Dingen, wenn er spielt, ist er eigentlich ganz gut. Also dieses letzte Spiel war gemalt, habe ich ganz selten stärker gesehen. Das Problem ist, ich glaube, das habe ich auch schon vor der Saison bei unserer Vorschau gesagt, dass ich glaube, wenn du ohne emmeres System gegen den Ball siehst, dann ist er da ein Wagerbund, der nicht zulässt, dass jemand etwas zulässt. Und Özil gegen den Ball, schwierig. Und ich glaube, das ist die Problematik, dass wenn du den zentral einbaust in diesem Pressingspiel, dann kann dir Mesut Özil das nicht geben. Du müsstest ihn also von diesen Pflichten befreien. Ich glaube, dass Emery letztlich nicht dazu bereit ist und vielleicht sogar jetzt einfach den Sommer nutzt, wo Aaron Ramsey gehen wird, wo dann womöglich auch, vielleicht auch schon im Winter Mesut Özil gehen wird und er dann einfach sagt, okay, wir sind sowieso am Umbauen, dann bauen wir doch gleich mal richtig um. Und all das strukturelles Özil ja dann auch rausfallen. Ich muss ehrlich sagen, am Anfang, die erste, in Anführungszeichen, Rückenverletzung, ich habe das Spiel damals übertragen und habe noch etwas suffizient gesagt, ja, Mesut Özil hat sicher eine Rückenverletzung. Das war einfach eine der Pausen, die ihm Wenger ja auch öfter mal gegönnt hat, was ihm auch innerhalb der Mannschaften so ein bisschen den Status leicht verändert hat, weil er schon eine Sonderstellung nahm. Jetzt hat er ein paar Mal öfter Rückenprobleme gehabt, die ihn zur Pause gezogen haben. Ich habe nicht gedacht, dass das so schnell geht, weil Emery eigentlich ihn schon mag, glaube ich, und auch den Spielertypen mag, aber halt sieht, dass das Gegend den Ball zu wenig ist, zu wenig auch für das, was er an Intensität braucht und vorhat in dieser Premier League, um bestehen zu können. Und Emery will Titel und nichts anderes. Und so würde ich sagen, dass spätestens im Sommer sich das trennt. Das ist aktuell meine Einschätzung. Ich würde mir das nicht wünschen, weil ich Özil inzwischen kriminell unterbewertet in Deutschland.
Da haben auch durchaus ein paar Kriminelle vielleicht mit Aussagen zu beigetragen.
Ja, das kommt leider erschwerend dazu. Aber das ist ja auch gerade sowieso ein Thema, auch in der Premier League mit Blick auf schwarze Spieler, dass da ein bisschen was los ist. Ja, ich würde mir eigentlich wünschen, dass das weitergeht bei Arsenal. Aber ich könnte auch damit leben, wenn Özil halt seine Momente noch in einem anderen Trikot zeigt, vielleicht in einem anderen Land, was vielleicht dann auch für ihn und seine Marketing-Maschinerie im Hintergrund noch mal klüger wäre. Da muss ich halt dann damit leben. Ehrlich gesagt, ich glaube nicht mehr, dass der da noch der große Stammspieler wird. Und das, glaube ich, tut er sich nicht an, von der Bank zu kommen.
Ja, dann können wir ja mal abwarten. Auf seiner Bucketlist wären noch Italien und Frankreich frei. Zum Beispiel, wenn es jetzt tatsächlich nach Ländern ginge. Abschließende Frage, was sagt denn das über den Sportjournalismus sowohl drüben in den UK als auch hier in Deutschland aus, wenn ich in halbwegs seriösen Berichten über Mesut Özil lese, er solle seine Rückenprobleme haben, weil er so viel Fortnite spielt. Also läuft die Diskussion in den UK auch wirklich so, oder hat sich das –das kann jetzt auch sein, dass das jetzt nur die Sun geschrieben hat, und dann hat es halt irgendein deutscher Journalist in seinen Artikel auch mit reingeschrieben, und dann –sowas verbreitet sich ja auch schnell. Aber ich finde das interessant, weil ich mich nicht auf Medien mit Boulevard-Bezug aufhalte und trotzdem diesen Fortnite-Rücken gelesen habe.
Also ich sag dir mal folgendes. Ich war mit meinem Bruder neulich –ich mache keine Werbung, aber ich war neulich in einem größeren Multimedia-Markt, und dann gab es da irgendein Fan-Artikel von Fortnite, und dann hat mein Bruder gesagt, guck mal, das wär doch was für mich so öse, und ich wusste es gar nicht. Und ich mache Woche für Woche Premier League-Spiele und lese viel über Arsenal.
Okay, aber dann …Was willst du dazu sagen? Nee, genau, mich hat auch das gar nicht …Also, das war jetzt nicht der Punkt, wo ich drauf wollte, weil das kann sich jeder schon denken, dass ich so eine Berichterstattung jetzt nicht so toll finde. Aber ich wollte wissen, ist das quasi auch das Niveau, auf dem über Özil in UK diskutiert wird, oder war das jetzt quasi so eine einmalige Boulevard-Spitze, die bei mir auch angekommen ist?
Bestimmt gibt es das irgendwo. Ich meide dann solche Artikel und Seiten auch. Bestimmt mag es das irgendwo geben. Aber das ist dann auch da nicht der Mainstream. So clever sind die schon. Die wüssten, es wird...
Ja, witzig. Und jetzt ist dir dein Nachbar, glaube ich, auch ganz kurz auf die Leitung getreten. Wir hatten den allerersten Aussetzer. Das ist die höchste Zeit, Uli, dass wir jetzt dann auch Schluss machen. Wir danken dir schon mal deinem Nachbar, dass er irgendwann aufgehört hat, zu bohren. Das war Uli Hebel. Add Uli Hebel auf Twitter von Das Sauen Uli. Vielen Dank dir, dass du dir mal wieder Zeit genommen hast. Und euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Das war jetzt mal ein Premier League-Kurzpass, der sich nur auf die großen Vereine konzentriert hat. Das nächste Mal gucken wir dann auch mal wieder auf die kleineren. Aber das war jetzt irgendwie auch mit der Champions League-Auslosung irgendwie ganz passend, fand ich. Vielen Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Es geht dann weiter mit einer Schlusskonferenz, die am Donnerstagnachmittag erscheint und dann noch eine letzte in der Nacht auf Weihnachten. Könnte es etwas schöneres geben. Bis dahin eine gute Zeit euch, macht's gut, ciao.